if another filmmaker wanted to emulate
what you and Tim Hetherington have done
with these two films what would you
advise to them I think in order to
repeat what Tim and I did you have to
you filmmaker would have to understand
first and foremost that documentary film
is journalism it's not a vehicle for
your opinions it's not a public service
announcement it's not a commentary on
the war or anything else it's a
documentary it's documenting reality if
you go into that situation any situation
with a real neutrality people pick up on
that and they respect it and they'll
talk to you
and the only thing Tim and I were
interested in was in the physical and
emotional reality of combat and other
great journalists were evaluating the
war and having a political discussion
and all that very important to and I
we're not doing that and if you want to
do if you as a filmmaker would want to
duplicate what Tim and I did you would
have to find that place in yourself
where you're really not judging you're
just trying to understand it's hard to
do but I think it's a crucial part of
the it's a crucial part of the work done
by the media is to under just understand
a basic reality terms what some people
are going through
you